let's give ourselves some practice
substituting positive and negative
values for variables so we're told to
evaluate X might result to evaluate X
minus negative Y where X is equal to
negative 2 and y is equal to 5 so
everywhere we see an X we could replace
with the negative 2 everywhere we see a
why we replaced with a 5 so this is the
Y right over here and then of course and
then of course this is an X so let's do
that so instead of that X let's write
negative 2 so we have negative 2 minus
and then we have open parenthesis a
negative why Y is equal to Y is equal to
5 now what is this going to evaluate to
well this is the same thing as negative
2 now subtracting a negative 5 so all of
this business here subtracting a
negative 5 that's the same thing as
adding a 5 it's going to be negative 2
plus 5 which is equal to 3 this is going
to be equal to 3 and there's several
ways to think about this on my brain
things okay I'm starting at negative 2
if I add 2 I get to 0 and then I would
have to add another and then I have to
add another 3 so that gets me to 3 you
could even view this as you could even
view this my brain kind of says negative
2 well let's see I have to add I have to
add 2 to get back to 0 and then I have
to add another 3 if I want to add a
total of 5 so this is going to be 0 plus
3 gets me to 3 another way to think
about it negative 2 plus 5 is the same
thing as 5 minus 2 5 minus 2 which is of
course equal to 3 or you can of course
draw it on a number line and you would
say if you start at negative 2 and you
take five steps to the right you get to
positive 3 let's do another one of these
this one's a little bit more a little
bit more complex so let's see we're told
to evaluate 3 minus negative 6 plus
negative H plus negative 4 where H is
equal to negative 7 well there's two
ways you could do it I could just take
the negative 7 and replace it
H with that negative seven or I could
actually try to simplify this expression
first and then do the substitution for H
so let's actually do that I my brain
feels like doing that so this expression
I have the three but instead of
subtracting a negative six instead of
subtracting a negative six that's going
to be the same thing just adding 6 so 3
plus 6 and adding a negative H adding a
negative H adding a negative H that's
the same thing as just subtracting H so
3 plus 6 minus H and then adding a
negative 4 adding a negative 4 that's
the same thing as subtracting 4 that's
the same thing as subtracting 4 and now
of course we can do this in any we you
know
addition and subtraction we have we can
we can change the order in which we do
it so let's let's do that just to kind
of simplify all of this so actually
first of all I can figure out what 3
plus 6 is 3 plus 6 is equal to 9 and
then I have this minus 4 here so I could
say 9 minus 4 like she I want to be
careful not to skip any steps so 3 plus
3 plus 6 in a color that you can see so
3 plus 6 is 9 so that's 9 minus H minus
4 minus 4 now I could I could change the
order in which I do this addition or
subtraction so this is going to be the
equivalent of 9 minus 4 9 minus 4 minus
H minus H and I just did that so I can
simplify and figure out what 9 minus 4
is 9 minus 4 of course let me do some
blue and navy blue 9 minus 4 is 5 so
this whole thing simplifies to 5 minus H
before I even did the substitution and
now I can substitute H with negative 7
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to when I do the
substitution I'll write it up here it's
going to be 5 minus under the minus of
that magenta color - and now it's where
I see an H I'm going to replace it with
negative 7
five minus negative seven you want to be
very careful that you might be simply
zero I have a negative here negative
here let me just replace H with the
seven remember H is negative seven so
you're subtracting H you're going to
subtract negative seven this is 5 minus
negative seven which is the same thing
which is the same thing as 5 + 7 5 plus
7 which we all know is equal to 12 and
we're done
let's do a few more of these you can't
you can't really get enough practice
here this is some important foundational
skills for the rest of your mathematical
lives all right
so consider I don't array it make it too
stressed about it it's it at the
following number line all right so we
got a number line here and they let's
see they didn't mark off all the numbers
here this is negative 4 he is at this
point this is then we go to 2 so it
looks like we're counting by twos here
that this is negative 2 this is 0 yep
negative 4 if you increase by 2 negative
4 negative 2 0 2 4 this would be a 6
this would be a negative 6 they
intentionally left those numbers off so
we have to figure out that hey look
between negative 4 & 2 that you have to
to go from negative 4 to 2 if to
increase by 6 and we only have 1 2 3
hash marks so each of those hash marks
must be increasing by 2 well anyway now
we know now we know what all the points
on the number line are evaluate E - f
well we know we know that E is equal to
negative 2 and we know we know that F is
equal to 4 so this is going to be the
same thing e is equal to negative 2 - -
positive 4 - positive 4 let me do that
same blue color - 4 well negative 2
minus 4 we have the number line in front
of us this is just going to be negative
6 if you start at negative 2 you
subtract if you subtract 2 you get 2
negative 4 you subtract another 2 you
get 2 negative 6 so we are done let's do
one more of these let's evaluate t plus
negative u or
again tea and you are on this number
line and it looks like each of these
hash marks we're incrementing by three
as we go up zero three six and if we go
down zero negative three negative six so
it's clear that U is equal to three U is
equal to three and it is also clear that
T is equal to negative six T is equal to
negative six so T plus negative U is
going to be so it's going to be negative
six plus negative six plus negative u U
is three U is three you want to be very
careful you might say oh I'll use
positive so I'm just gonna put a
positive number here but remember it's
negative you wherever see either you
replace it with the three so it's
negative three so this is going to be
six plus negative three or starting
negative six plus negative three which
we can rewrite it as negative six minus
three all of this business could be
re-written as negative six minus 3
negative six minus three if you're at
negative six and you go three to the
left you go three more negative you're
going to end up at negative nine and
we're all done